- What did you do?
- I thought it was gonna be
really easy and it wasn't.
Why did it do that?
(electronic music)
Today, YouTube is going to teach
us how to cut our own hair.
I'm not as nervous as
I probably should be.
- I'm scared shitless, so
let's see where that goes.
The first 30 minutes, we're gonna
be watching a tutorial video.
After that, we get 30
minutes to cut our own hair.
And then right after, we'll
be going around the office
asking people how much they
think our haircut cost.
- Wait, you're not
going to take any notes?
You're just going by memory?
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Do you, I'm not telling
you how to live your life.
- None of this is helping me at all.
- Are you scrubbing through your tutorial?
- Yeah, because I'm impatient, I'm sorry.
- Are you ready to cut your hair?
- I have no choice, so
let's just get this over with, please.
- Let's cut some hair.
30 minutes starts now.
- Now.
- This just got so real.
I'm doing my ponytail
at the top of my head.
Holy moly.
- Oh, shit.
I'm going to start with an eight.
Meaning that it's not
going to cut that much.
Why did it just go weak?
It's literally just vibrating.
Ah, thank you.
- There you go.
I'm supposed to cut right
above this hair tie.
Here goes nothing.
It's not going through as
easily as I thought it would.
I'm cutting it crooked, what's happening?
(Ken gasps)
Look at this, that's not how
that was supposed to happen.
- Syd.
That's my hair.
Okay, remove this and make
it into three sections.
Okay.
Fuck, look at this.
What am I doing, you guys?
(rock music)
So here's the one that I've
like fixed a little bit,
versus the one that has not been fixed.
And I feel like they look better.
(razor buzzing)
- There's no going back now.
Oh, man.
- It still looks pretty blunt.
I'm going to do what I just did over.
How much time do we have?
- 17 minutes.
- 17 minutes, okay.
(upbeat music)
- Going in the back.
How do they do this?
- It actually, I don't
think it looks that bad.
I mean, it gets a little rough over here.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh my gosh wait, look at this.
I don't know how to fix this.
- Oh, Jesus.
- Now I'm straying from the tutorial.
I'm just going by memory.
The last time I got my haircut in August.
I'm just trying to remember
what my hairstylist does.
But I don't think she's ever
fucked up my hair this bad.
She definitely hasn't,
she's wonderful at her job.
- We have 12 minutes
You know what, fuck it.
I'll just have to go to this
side because this looks...
Oh man, I fucked up so bad.
- Was my hair this long when we started?
Yeah, okay so it looks
like I only cut this much
and this stuff right
here is just hanging out.
- I think I feel a lot more
confident on this side.
I think it's going to look
way better on the right side.
Oh yeah, okay.
Now I'm getting the hang of this.
- Well, I'm not.
I'm just gonna,
there goes my hair.
It's on the ground now.
- I think I should just
give up on my back.
- This is not what this is
supposed to look like you guys.
I know what a haircut's
supposed to look like,
and this isn't it.
Okay well, I think I give up now, so.
- Well, I can't really give up because
at least I want to look
decent when I come out here.
- Maybe it's something where
our coworkers will not know.
- No. (laughs)
Please be merciful.
- Hey, the alarm's going off.
(Ken groans)
(Ken laughs)
- I mean, it's not like totally even,
but I don't think it looks as bad
as you think it does.
- Compare this side.
- Okay.
- To this side.
- That side looks much better.
- Well, here's my hair.
- Honestly, if I look from far away,
oh, wait.
(laughing)
- Before we've asked
anybody their opinions,
would you do this again?
- Definitely not.
- I absolutely would not.
- I think I've learned my lesson.
- I've learned my lesson.
But, I don't know.
I'm excited to see what
our coworkers have to say.
- I'm not (laughing).
- How much do I think you
paid for your haircut?
70 dollars?
- I cut it myself.
- (laughing) What?
Okay, now that you point it
out, yeah, it's a little blunt.
It's a little blunt.
(laughing)
Oh that's fucked up.
- It definitely smells
like it was blow dried,
so I think you got it done.
- That's just your regular hair smell?
Damn, you have nice-smelling
hair. (laughing)
- Okay, it smells like you just showered.
- Okay, I think they're low-end haircuts.
- Are they the same or different?
I think you did them yourselves.
- [Ken] We did.
- I know, I can tell.
(all laughing)
- The only reason is that
there's one little part
that's like not fully blended.
- A little uneven in the back.
Yours looks great.
But also a little uneven.
Did you like do these to each other?
- [Sydnee] We did them to ourselves.
- To yourselves?
That's impressive.
Like, honestly, wow.
Yeah, they definitely don't
look like expensive haircuts.
(upbeat music)